bald ganz ganz bald wahrscheinlich schon
in einer woche sich dann nach und
herzlich willkommen 29 video heute
spielen wir eine runde
minecraft jump league und ich habe
gerade eben wieder richtig hart
gesündigt leute ich hab gerade ein
kleines fleisch gehabt und ich habe
einfach mal ich weiß sie also ich mache
ich gestörte sachen wenn ich so fresh
fresh träge gerade eben zum beispiel
einfach nutella spur von aus teelöffeln
hesse komitees das verletzt aber wieder
ich bin heute minecraft jump league
endlich mal wieder und nachdem die
letzte folge dass gemäß ich nicht allzu
krass war wollen wir heute mal probieren
das ganze ein bisschen besser zu machen
ein bisschen mehr reinzuhauen wir haben
hier irgend einen ziemlichen auflauf
verursacht habe ich gefühlt wie meine
mutter früher was meinte ist dass wir
gerade mal bis in der lobby umgekehrt
haben also ich stand einfach herum und
dann haben sie die extrem viele leute
angesammelt ich glaube dass jetzt ein
paar mit in der runde
das heißt die wissen wahrscheinlich auch
schon dass ich der mit dem nickname bin
werden versuchen mich auf gemeinste art
und weise im deathmatch weg zu tage was
machen wir dagegen keine ahnung ich hab'
ich habe nicht mehr marmelade hier kein
nutella
ich könnte nicht mal den fuß
nein leute warum erzähle ich euch sowas
überhaupt das macht überhaupt keinen
sinn machen
aber okay so ich glaube heute wird das
deutlich besser hier bisher läuft
eigentlich gut vielleicht können wir die
runde hier kompakt in zehn minuten
abschließen das während im ich hab traum
von mir hab ich schon bisschen länger
darüber nachgedacht dass das was wird
so was wir dafür immer noch drauf
stoner ex level festigt bisschen weit
unten
könnte man nicht am stück mache erstmal
den checkpoint da drüben mitnehmen
werden erreichen
ultimative film schön wenn die scharfen
jackpot zu erreichen
30 fans klarmachen kennt ihr das
eigentlich schon das ist ghani sprache
hat maximal videos verendet die harris
richten so leute die man selber vor uns
das kann ich natürlich nicht tolerieren
laut seiner macher man speedrun okay
dann eben doch nicht ich glaube ich bin
concorde kongo davon ist richtig knapp
gerade aber wir können das schaffen
würde ich sagen was passiert sonst
geradezu spannendes in eurem life sei
der gerade hassel ich habe noch die
semesterferien leute und bald ganz ganz
bald wahrscheinlich schon in einer woche
zieh ich dann nach berlin um in berlin
ein praktikum zu machen
da habe ich cooler weise die möglichkeit
gefunden bei einem kollegen
unterzukommen richtig richtig neu ist
sehr korrekt für eine echt coole wohnung
relativ zentral sogar das heißt dann
kann ich dann in berlin einiges machen
kann alle möglichen menschen besuchen
gröner für zwei euro essen hoffentlich
wobei ich das immer noch für mythos
heute das ist wirklich keine ahnung
hessens werten oder genießbaren döner
für zwei euro gibt sich schon auf den
berlin gut nie so wirklich weit draußen
aber trotzdem ich habe nie irgendwas
gesehen was auch nur annähernd da dahin
kommt ja mal 280 oder so aber nie glatt
2 euro was müsste man mal schreiben muss
sowas gibt falls sie aus berlin kommt
und wisst wo es gibt dann haut es mal
rein
ja und die sache ist ich hab halt noch
gar keine ahnung wie man hier lang läuft
und genauso wenig ahnung wie ich den
umzug gestalten soll weil ich keine
ahnung ich habe noch keinen umzugs
fahrzeug und ich glaube ich brauche auch
keins
weil ich nicht so ewig viel zeit habe
ich hab meine mein zimmer halt in meinem
studienautor untervermietet habe dann
auch bisschen zeug drin beziehungsweise
also die möbel sind ganz drin und dann
noch was im keller so ein bisschen zeuge
im keller gelegt kann man hier so rüber
also geht es glaube ich alter kommen
hoch ach so jetzt hier richtig
erschreckt so so ja und dann brauche ich
eigentlich kein lieferwagen aber frage
ist wie komme ich sonst hoch ich glaube
mein vater für sein auto nicht geht ich
habe schon gefragt ob er muss umziehen
dadurch haben er war von dem vorschlag
eher weniger begeistert was ich
natürlich bisschen schade finde
deswegen muss man mal gucken wieder
hochkomme mein eigenes auto werde ich
natürlich nicht mit nach berlin nehmen
weil es keinen sinn macht gerade wenn
ich dann in relativ zentral vielleicht
wohne hallo da als ob man da so hier rum
alter okay jetzt
ach was man dort immer weniger oder wie
aber kann auch hoch man kann mit neid
nein man kann nicht versuchen vorne /
haupttäter nicht schick stunden später
ihr könnt mir auch mal wenn ihr selbst
aus berlin kommt niemand akku des spots
spots sportparcours orte reinschreiben
die irgendwie kennt und mögt und in den
ihr gerne seit wir euch vorstellen
könnte das das aus für mich wäre dann
sammle ich ein bisschen mal die
vorschläge
hehe ok man kann aber auch glaube ich
hierhin ja rodneis ich glaub jetzt
gesehen ich bin einfach nicht hoch
gesprungen sie kommen jetzt noch einmal
hoch könnte klappen
falls nicht einfach meiner steinachs
instead i o ich wollte ehrlich diese
ohne mal gewinnen
dankeschön da müssen wir wieder richtig
rum herzen dann irgendwie im deathmatch
was zu reißen
so jetzt kommt auch mal die richtung
anziehen
ich hab mich zu ich muss ich kurz
umziehen jungs privatsphäre
zack zack zack
ich habe mein dad weggeschmissen nicht
so schlau
ich habe dann level bitte bitte bitte
bitte bitte dass der management pack weg
bitte bitte ok erst mal in ihrer klasse
a
das ist irgendwie grün was machen grüne
hinter mir oder hinter mir ein
als ob übertreibt was das für hits alter
junge krass dann gehe ich mal lieber von
dem weg bleiben ich glaube ich negativen
pink so und jetzt hier
ok entscheiden bugs immer noch da angel
haben wir auch so kurz wie noch
funktioniert also mit entscheiden und
back my nicht dass man ihr wisst schon
dass man obwohl man ein level hat nicht
entscheiden kann
nein nein aber die irgendwie 2 level
versprochen joachim überall gegner
altafaj chip aber noch drei leben neu
ordnen falsche hand als ob er gisborne
camp hat wie freudig und dann noch so
walter medaille gerade so ich wäre first
gewinn nachbarn hält man nicht von nine
nine mitten in die ecke und putten die
in the corner
das ist gerade richtig richtig nass aber
der typ grad eben war schon ne wobei
manchmal einfach behindert also nicht
behindert sondern ungünstig spawn
einfach dann direkt neben dem ort wo
grad eben steiner des portes der keine
natürlich theoretisch es sieht aus wie
es born kelling
wahrscheinlich hat das nicht mit absicht
gemacht hat was wollt ihr glaube sowieso
ränder power box
er boxt mal rockig mal poppig mal pro
jahr
nice sehr schön so richtig schön
als ich von mir ab in richtung mit ihm
sollen da wir aber nicht mehr das war es
jetzt okay okay okay okay dass ich dort
meine drop über wie dumm wie drum alter
aber wisst ihr was ich kann mir auf die
vorteile kräften
vielleicht sollte ich das auch machen
und den verbissen post bei den kollegen
oder kommt auch noch eine mauer
nein nein nein nein nein nein pilz
donnerstag nie ich hab doch überhaupt
nichts grafing terry platzieren
wie geht s noch mal was mit der flinte
und mitgenommen osec ist oder nicht
wo sind sie hin die jamal so die fenster
vorweg alles klar
dann greife ich mir keine pfeile war
aber die wussten mit ihm können also
einfach kurz hier um die ecke und dann
mit dem bogen loerken ja alles klar okay
werden wir noch mit der axt gegeben
als ob man wie viel leben hatte der denn
what the [ __ ] okay aber ich kann mir da
alle kräften nämlich wirklich eine
finsternis ja ok kommen dann kräftig mit
der angel hatte wegen die nochmal so
glaube ich na ja okay wenn man hin aber
wieder an
die ist echt ganz witzig teilweise also
angel bringt schon nicht so drauf hat
damit kann man doch noch wie gerade eben
in diesem einen moment sicher gehen wenn
man auch nicht dass man den first hit
kriegt was dann passiert ist was anderes
aber dafür sich schon ganz gut so oder
zum beispiel um leute beim verfolgen ein
bisschen aus dem konzept zu bringen
dafür sorgen die wende rein fliegen so
kompakt jetzt lauf nicht so lange weg
ok erweitert er fightet jetzt kommt der
andere länder auch ronny kommt schon ich
bin ich völlig kalt gekämpft habe okay
ist nichts die nämlich noch mit
die boots jetzt noch zwei leben für
diesen kampf
er will sich direkt falten ich habe
glaube ich noch mindestens einen fall
also mindestens einen fall ja dass sie
gut aussah jetzt konnte ich will nicht
laufen konnte auspacken was sollte das
war so ein bisschen die story von meinem
umzug und einer unter jump league die
eigentlich echt die war gut würde ich
sagen nur die leute packen halt gerne
mal so lächerliche drei kommen muss
ausnahmslos sind wir sehen zunächst
wieder ein machtwort